this morning we are getting an inside
look at a new show that repairs homes
that were damaged in natural disasters
but here's the catch there are only five
days that's the max to fix up each home
and some of these are in really bad
shape the show is called Fast home
rescue and it stars Cody and Felicia
Walker they are the brother and
sister-in-law of the late actor Paul
Walker the married couple runs the
disaster relief organization Reach Out
worldwide which Paul founded back in
2010. in this clip the Walkers show The
Walls family how they renovated their
home in Dawson Springs Kentucky hard hit
by a historic ef4 tornado a monster in
December 2021.
it's reveal day and the Walls family has
just arrived to see their newly
remodeled house for the first time since
the tornado hit do you want to go take
it to the inside yes we are just as
anxious as you guys are let's do it for
the rest of the house let's do it all
right let's do it
all right you guys are you ready
[Music]
such a great moment Cody and Felicia
join us now uh and Cody's wearing his
favorite shirt clearly yeah
go Cody
I I love in that episode with the Walls
family first of all you come to their
home and you kick them out of their home
because it's work and you tell them no
drive-bys no Peaks we're going to take
care of this five days and the clock is
ticking starts right in there uh Felicia
you were a civil engineer before doing
this I was uh and you were a paramedic
before getting into this yeah so I'd
love each you to take the question what
Drew you to these projects
um you know Reach Out worldwide was
something that we immediately jumped in
two feet after Paul passed we had
totally different life up in Oregon but
when the board called on Cody to
continue this we both went down there
packed up our dog and just jumped in two
feet you know we we had a lot of work to
do it was really hard to get it to the
point that it is now but it's something
that we're super proud of it's a piece
of Paul that he left behind and it just
evolved you know we went from doing muck
and guts and Chainsaw work to renovating
whole homes
I love the language of it also the one
day I think I could help you with is
demo day
everyone loves a good demo
but how much work do these homes need
so when we come in uh the the the the
principal structure needs to be there
right we have five days so we have to
have a roof and we have to have framing
Rider walls we come in we put in new
flooring we build the kitchens we build
the bathrooms we we get it all uh
prepared and we leave it furnished for
the homeowner and a lot of these
homeowners have been living in a FEMA
trailer or they've been living with
other families since the disaster and
they just there's no they don't have any
other option yeah the Walls family there
their kitchen we didn't show it but it
was basically open to the elements their
doors ripped off of cabinets it was a
mess but I'm fascinated guys that you
were able to do this in only five days
you give yourself a five day deadline
and you work strictly on donations
that's why this is so important that you
count on the donations to get you
through but how are you able to do it
Cody in five days because as Tony said
the kitchen's over there the living
room's over there and in some cases it
doesn't exist yeah yeah um we just we
have incredible volunteers
um the five-day rule you the five-day
rule yeah uh that was not my choice not
at all
um and we the thing is though is we have
12 homes that we got to do in 12 weeks
so if we took two weeks we would get to
do six homes so it was a challenge that
you know we kind of laid on ourselves I
guess you know we wanted to do more work
for more people yeah but you all love a
good reveal yes yes it's just we're all
a sucker for it what is that moment like
when they walk into that home oh it's
very emotional and every each homeowner
you'll see each week has a has a very
different way of processing what's going
on sometimes there's tears immediately
sometimes it's just a State of Shock
because their house did not look
anything like that five days ago but I
mean five days you could have a
conversation about a wall paint color
for five years where to put a chair in a
room for five days you know and the
secret is it's not even five days you
know the first four the first day we
meet the family we do the walkthrough we
can't start work because they gotta get
the before shots right so all of that
happens on Monday then we get to come in
we get to see it we get to visualize it
and then we go shopping we have to
Source locally what's available and
guess what you guys do it something
tells me your brother your lookalike
brother you look just like him so great
to see you smiling down he's smiling
down so Bravo and congratulations thank
you so much continue to sort Cody and
Felicia Walker you can watch the series
premiere of fast home rescue on the
Weather Channel tomorrow at 8 7 Central